her social media feed saturated with
disturbing self-harm content Molly
Russell was 14 when she took her own
life those closest to her unaware of her
suffering it almost makes you think like
oh did I really know her
I think it was shocking to see that and
to see that it was that bad even years
later it is a particularly complex form
of grief to process for the friends she
left behind so lose a friend at that age
it's it's scarring Devine and Molly made
friends doing school plays together Les
Mis and Beauty and the Beast she had
just been given like one of the lead
roles for the show that we were doing
that year either depression or you know
poor mental health can hide almost in
plain sight in that sense the night
before Molly died all had seemed fine at
rehearsals the next day an empty seat I
thought oh maybe she's she's not well
today I texted another friend asking
like oh have you seen Molly is she okay
and I think I actually texted Molly as
well asking why she wasn't in school
taken to a classroom where Devine's
parents were waiting a teacher explained
when I first thought was no
and it was like an instant sense of like
doubt like No mollywood And what that
didn't even make sense
and I remember being ushered into
um our drama classroom actually
which was
filled with I don't know maybe 30 or 40
um girls and other students as well
all crying and that's a sound I can't
forget the sound of that many
um children just
in such emotion before taking her own
life Molly left a note quoting an
Instagram post which said I'm just not
good enough she was so loved by all of
us and
I think if she saw how
much pain we were going through knowing
that she was gone I don't think she
would have made that choice I think she
genuinely believed that we would be
better off without her her family would
later learn that alone in her room's
social media algorithms had been feeding
Molly content too disturbing to show
here
in a landmark conclusion into the cause
of death the coroner decided social
media romanticized acts of self-harm
normalized her condition and that some
content discouraged Molly from
discussion with those who may have been
able to help ultimately contributing to
her death
it's not about whether it's there in the
first place it's about the way that they
recommend and push children into feeling
absolute despair it is inhuman and it
has to be illegal we have to have some
Protections in place to say actually you
don't get to grow or have profit on the
life the good health the well-being
of our kids I want people to know that
what happened to Molly Isn't an isolated
event and the content that she's being
pushed it still exists today on
Instagram many of the hashtags Molly
searched for have now been blocked but
not all of them as Sky News is data and
forensics units has been finding out
we're not going to read them out because
we don't want anyone to look them up but
actually you found that some of the
content that was shown at the inquest it
is still searchable yeah that's right so
one in particular actually that Molly's
dad mentioned a particular method of
suicide if I type the hashtag in
we see that it is blocks as you maybe
expect but there does seem to be a bit
of a sort of back door way into it which
is if I don't type the full hashtag
but just part of it I actually get an
auto suggestion to go to that hashtag
and when I click on it I do get taken
there
we raised this with Instagram though
didn't we and they did initially take
down or completely block this hashtag
didn't they but but that's since changed
yeah it has so as mentioned it seems as
though that now once again going through
the autofill route we can see what's
been posted related to that hashtag it
is worth mentioning that a lot of the
harmful content has been taken down from
that hashtag but now anyone putting new
material on there marked with that same
tag would go straight on there and would
once again be searchable and so that's a
bit worrying really in reply to this
meta who owned Instagram told us we've
already been working on new parental
supervision tools that let parents see
who their teens follow we also have
controls designed to limit the types of
content TNC we don't allow content that
promotes suicide or self-harm
125 young lives are lost to Suicide a
week and from those working with young
people there's concern about how social
media can sometimes heighten feelings of
depression and anxiety
on both kind of researcher in this field
but I'm also a father as well and it
absolutely terrifies me and I don't
think we're really going to see what the
long-term impacts of this are maybe
until 10 15 years down the line but one
thing we are seeing is a real crisis in
children young people's mental health so
every month right now we're seeing
record numbers of young people being
referred to their GPS and doctors for
more mental health support research by
Young Minds shared exclusively with Sky
News suggests harmful content is a
growing problem
at least once a week more than a fifth
of young people are automatically shown
distressing content by social media
platforms based on their previous online
activity nearly all the young people who
have had mental health problems say
social media helps Drive harmful
behaviors and over half said they had
sought out content which they knew might
make them distressed or uncomfortable
and so far the only real way to protect
young people from harmful content is to
employ people to watch it extremely
violent could be homophobic pedophilia I
was just so so stressed
this woman wants to remain anonymous to
enable her to talk to us about working
for a leading social media company as a
former content moderator it was her job
to sift through and tag thousands of
harmful posts every day you don't have
any time to process it because you just
have to continue with another video you
have 30 seconds to watch it and then tag
it and all the things you need to tag so
you just go on with your day and then
it's not until after you finish that
you're even able to process what you saw
it really had come to the point where I
felt so unwell that I literally couldn't
work I had to call my GP to advise me
not to do it anymore
and I won't go into like personally
exactly what happened I mean it wasn't
far off from you know how Molly was I
can recognize the feelings in how I felt
seeing all this content coming at me
what does it feel like they are sort of
in control of what what is it on these
platforms as well absolutely not the
system was just there was chaos no one
really knew what was happening we're
just a lot of like young just finished
their degree 20 year olds sat there
trying to figure out how to judge all
this content with no legal background
this is a big company just trying to
make money and they don't care about you
know how that content affects people and
it's that sense of conflict between
taking responsibility for the impact and
influence that these platforms have and
ultimately making a profit which is the
bottom line here many of the social
media companies that we've spoke to said
they are committed to making social
media safe but with millions of users
and millions more posts placing it is no
small task the internet is is a bit of a
wild west when it comes to trying to
regulate it so as soon as you come up
with one model that you think will help
build walls around what we have right
now people naturally find a way out
there so what's needed actually is a
real kind of agile piece of legislation
a real agile regulatory framework that
includes the voices of young people that
is constantly involving so that we can
really kind of keep on top of that the
government has been accused of dragging
its feet when it comes to introducing
legislation to regulate social media
firms but now after years of delay the
Online safety bill is back before
Parliament next week proposing fines for
tech companies of up to 10 of their
turnover if they fail to protect users
from harmful content and criminalizing
posts that encourage self-harm this is a
fundamentally important piece of
legislation especially to protect
children and it is vital that we get it
done at this session the whole
government is behind that mission and
we're going to do it but the Molly Rose
Foundation says the bill has been
watered down to appease-free speech
campaigners like baroness Fox who
threatened to oppose it now taken out
the removal of measures that would have
forced social media sites to take down
material designated harmful but legal
the danger is that we on the back of a
very emotional response to something
like the tragedy of Molly Russell bring
in a piece of legislation that doesn't
just protect children but actually
infantilizes adults and treats them like
children and if you're a free speech
campaigner as I am this bill is a major
serious censorship tool everybody who
has raped over the bill again and again
and again would like it to be product
safety we do not deliver cars without
breaks and rear view mirrors and so
forth and we must not deliver Tech
without breaks and rear view mirrors and
so forth I think they have blood on
their hands at this point because they
have not heeded previous
uh cries for help for Molly's family and
friends like Devine it's been
emotionally exhausting fighting to
ensure the government's Online safety
bill is brought into law it's very big
news that they now want to kind of
incriminalize
um you know the harmful content and
anyone responsible for that but at the
same time it does feel like it's been an
awfully long journey but of course it
won't bring Molly back I've actually
still got her birthday present from uh
2017 so that would have been her 50th
birthday and of course she never made it
to that birthday and that present still
sits in my room at home
um because I'm just really not really
sure what to do with it
I obviously can't give it to her but I
think in some way it feels like I can
kind of hold on to her through that
Katie Spencer Sky News
well if you have been affected by that
story and want to talk to someone you
can call these Samaritans for free on
116123 or email Joe at samaritans.org